[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link this week at the round table of
dim lighting we're gonna talk about the
future with Derek Muller known
everywhere on the Internet as veritasium
amazing YouTube creator and
scientifically minded person who is uh
yep we have had a very stimulating
conversation we have had it we've had it
and we're teeing it up for you ear
biscuit ear a lot of fun for us to
speculate about things that will happen
in the future and I know that this is
it's striking it's speaking your love
language I'd like to talk about the
future I I'd like to talk about the
future with people who know things about
the future and actually have informed
guesses about the future as opposed to
myself that just has formed guesses
about the future foreign meeting you
formed it yeah you made them up meaning
I formed them meaning I got lots of
guesses about the future and I have
formula formulated them but they're not
in formulated this early so we get into
a lot of things in our conversation with
Derek and we also clear up I will say
that you're the one who made it awkward
but I think we cleared up something that
was a little it all start an
interpersonal conflict between Derek and
want to lay blame want to lay blame here
blame number one responsible party is
Derek Oh
number two responsible party is you
because of the way you reacted and
number I miss aim technical
responsibility he's the one who started
like scientific responsibility yeah but
that doesn't mean but then you got very
close second because of the way you took
it and now I'm just a guy who likes to
be entertained
I'm third on this totem pole man I'm
third you need to invert that okay
entirely alright you then me then dare
you can do that if you want but it was
fun and it was interesting and it it
might have been a little awkward I mean
his mom was watching for goodness sakes
that's
was so great I want to come on referee
so that's what you that's what you got
in store for you as you're listening
tonight I feel like you're listening at
night for some reason it's just alien
hitted everyone who doesn't listen at
night even if it's during the day it's
just it's not somewhere night in your
soul right now listening in here that's
the word listening a night of the soul
is like dark night of the soul that's a
bad thing
so we talked about we kind about cars
cars and I didn't mention this but we
can get into a little bit more we got a
the Neil's got a got a vehicle well
pretty big deal here a replacement
vehicle for for the illustrious minivan
now I haven't talked to you about this
but I wanted to and it does something
that is very futuristic right but but we
but we'll talk about that later because
the thing that the most interesting
aspect of this is the fact that you
unmanned which is a you know mini
vanning as a decision is already a bit
of a decision right I've never made that
decision and then you unmanned and I
just want to know what went into
essentially went into the process I mean
I've been a I've been a proud minivan er
for many years maybe seven years maybe
more than that more than that I've been
through three minivan you got one right
after you had your first kid oh yeah
so I mean no I didn't did I you had a
minivan with a second kid bro Devin I
was with Lincoln so we're talking 12
years which two kids does not require a
minivan so yeah we made a choice to go
for it for the spaciousness and in the
drivability man it drives like a car it
fits a lot of people in it's very
practical and get a lot of people in it
I remember right when we got it we went
on a whitewater rafting trip and it was
me my dad you Greg Greg's dad and
another person and I was like oh we'll
take the minivan yeah you know it's like
it's perfect and while I appreciate all
that I have a certain level of pride I'm
not saying it's a good thing but I
inferred and all I had to
kids I didn't need them anyway had a you
have a you have us but I'd stick my oh
yeah big well this you let this stigma
minivans have a stigma yeah so you know
in the way that in the way that our
families work is that you know we've got
the car that we typically drive and then
you've got the car that your wife
typically drives and she's gonna be the
one that has the bigger one because
she's picking up the kids from school
and and and more often dealing with them
than we are during the day but then oh I
wouldn't be caught dead driving a
minivan just me that's great
no but but I'm just saying that like
there are moments and I'm not saying
this is a healthy thing but there are
just times when I'm in a place and I
don't want people to just pigeonhole me
as the guy with the minivan so that's
the reason that I recognize how
practical is so just like I'm gonna get
an SUV that basically is I know it's not
as convenient harder to get in out of
all these things but it was just a sense
of external appearance that keeps a lot
of people from going to the minivan
you made a shallow choice to not get him
anywhere yeah but because made a deep
but because that's get a minute but that
is the way the world works because
people are shallow and so sometimes you
have to make shallow decisions to live
in a shallow world okay that if that
makes you feel better and you've now
made a shallow decision well I'll say
that years of being a minivan driver I
think got to us it's like we couldn't
you could we could only fight that good
fight so long and one day Chris you know
were just sitting down and there was a
just just we weren't you know it's just
one of those like silent moments it's
silent my kids aren't around here we are
just sitting down a moment of reflection
and then it's yeah I think it turned
reflection II reflective and then I
light reflection it could you should
just use that word then all of a sudden
Christie was like I wouldn't like
another minivan it was her it got to her
and I was like what did she say right
hold on did she's it sprays it exactly
that way cuz that it sounds so I
wouldn't like another minivan like
that's an interesting way to say um or
did you say that right now
I did say right now I heard myself say
it I
think that was her sentiment I can't I'd
you know I don't remember conversations
I'm willing to bet she did not just out
of the blue say I wouldn't like another
minivan and then I was like I - I'm in
agreement you guys are weird in your
reflection Airy moments reflection II I
was we were both feeling it you know
like the minivan was getting a lot of
miles once it breaks a hundred thousand
miles you got to replace the
transmission in that puppy yeah and I
did that twice I was like I'm not doing
that again
that's ones ain't the problems really
starts so then when we were going to get
in I was like we need we're breaking a
hundred grand in terms of miles not in
terms hundred grand on a minivan it gold
rim hundred thousand miles I'm we got to
get out from under it we got to get we
got a we got a shed this skin and we're
like well let's not get another mini but
was there a discussion beyond that or
was it just a feeling during a
reflection airy reflection a moment
where you tell you is we were in
agreement you vibed yeah yeah we
reviving about it and then so we wanted
that I mean with three kids we wanted a
car that had captains chairs in the
second row so then basically we got a we
we just picked an SUV that had captains
chairs in the second row so that the
kids wouldn't be in a bench seat they
have to have physical separation they
have to have their own seat or it's just
gonna be bad it can't be like oh that's
it's not about access to the back row
it's about physical separation that's
the first reason is everyone has their
own seat and it's not two people on a
big bench that then it's like well how
much of the bench are you taking I just
didn't want to have that argument so
that narrowed down what we're gonna go
with and I don't even want to say what
we bought because hey they're not paying
me and B I don't care enough to say hmm
honestly but I am tempted to brag a
little bit because it's got Auto parking
feature well well and I didn't know I
didn't really know that that cars had
this because I have a minivan with
100,000 miles on it
right but I saw like a mild on
commercial from like seven years ago
where they were to advertising this
technology and I probably saw it and I
was like death stupid I can park my own
car I'll one of the things that I took
the most pride in when I first started
dating Christie with my ability to park
in a space on a date and I would always
back in your sock in her I would back in
and she was really impressed with that I
would always back in my nice 1987 Nissan
becoming much less sound like you
insulted my wife or I can't figure out
did you insult me or my wife I'm just
saying a woman who is really impressed
by a man who backs in I'm just saying
mmm take it back
don't you don't assault my wife on I'm
insulting insult me I'm insulting you
through your wife that's the how that's
the way I went out of that way at that
time well I don't appreciate it okay I
take it all back and what I didn't even
hear I said I take it all back in
because you're about you're back in it's
actually an incredible joke and everyone
in the room laughed
you didn't get it because you spending
too much time thinking about backing
into spaces and that it out quick and
that's what matters that you said
something funny not the apology that's
fine yeah so anyway this car what it
only when it bet when it parks
automatically it does it by backing only
I didn't did you know that that's self
parking cars back in exclusively or at
least this one it will not go into a
because I know what parallel parks but
it also goes like your regular space a
proper parallel parking procedure is to
back in right you can't yet the physics
of how a car works right can't parallel
park knows first doesn't work nearly as
well but you can't even choose to pull
into a space yeah it'll it'll
automatically Park in in parking spaces
that are like normal like cars beside
each other not not into end but side by
side well but it will only back into
those and it's a scary thing and that
feels awesome but I've lost a little bit
of myself
givin myself over and that's what we
talked about when we talk about the
future is how much of ourselves are we
gonna give over to the robot overlords
we discussed that in depth well and I've
broken the seal personally now well it
makes me think that maybe again cuz we
talked about this as well about how I
have this faith in AI helping us being
be able to solve problems mm-hmm and
what you basically proven here link
yeah is that at least with your car the
AI has determined that the best way to
get into a spot is to back in which
might potentially settle our
long-standing argument and I'm going to
make up for insulting my wife I will
accept it I'm willing yes I think you're
missing the bigger point here finally I
the whole point I've been right the
whole time the whole point of appealing
to AI is that it is something beyond the
two people and they're flawed
understandings can a cheat now if
there's other cars out there that don't
just exclusively back in then you know
I'm gonna take it all back but at least
as far as this particular car company
they're not gonna mention is concern in
this particular model that you have is
earned if that's the AI we're deferring
to I love it you win the argument for
now yep until I get a car that pulls in
mm-hmm and you know what in the book of
mythicality which there are a limited
quantity of signed versions on our store
mythical dot store get them while the
getting's good if you want exclusive
signed book go there there is a there is
a full page dedicated to a photo of me
and my family and our minivan yeah there
it is an ollie
and so even though I've gotten rid of
her the minivan she will live on in the
book and because there's a great story
in the pick a fight chapter we also have
an entire chapter dedicated to the
future actually a chapter written from
the future that's true that I'm showing
now so lots of touch points to the book
of mythicality which can be yours
everywhere books are sold and book of
mythicality calm
signed one on a website now on with the
biscuit our grand futuristic
conversation with Derek from veritasium
I remember it was a bus and it was the
daytime and we were that's where we met
so with some YouTube event and then
there were guys who created weird
vehicles and they had like a YouTube
channel but they were they had an accent
but I don't know yeah they were
Australian they were Australian they're
these guys who do Mighty Car Mods
and you knew them yes or uh I'm also
kind of Australian kind of yeah I would
have nine there that was born there but
I don't have the accent right so right I
put one on if you like I mean you just
do it too late now that would really
enjoy as you played really annoy did you
ever have did you ever knowwwww know cuz
I I moved away when I was like 18 months
old we moved to Canada so I'm
essentially Canadian then I moved back
when I was 21 I lived there for a decade
but I think by the time you're 21 you've
got your accent you know what it's gonna
be
well now there are different kinds of
people because there are definitely
people who put on whoo no no there are
people who there's all right don't
that's the type adults who go to a place
like I had I don't remember this was but
I've had multiple friends who like just
went on a European vacation and they
come back talking differently people
were just so in they can be influenced
so easily I mean or they want to sound
that way I had a friend he went to
London for like six months and came back
and everything was like oh yeah you've
got a guard against that you got to go
in guarding against exactly and we just
met your mom she's she's here she is
indeed yes she's one keepin an eye on
April person she's visiting keeping an
eye on you here making sure we don't get
you in any trouble here on this ear
biscuit
hey if I if my mom was visiting and this
wasn't my show I don't know if I would
bring my mom to it because I just think
she would when it was over she just she
tried to be nice but she would just be
like it's
so boring yeah I don't I don't think my
mom would care too much about coming to
a podcast but she would like she wanted
to go to the doctors last time remember
that oh she and she needed to see a
doctor no the doctors the show okay and
she took Kristi and Jesse she loved it
yeah she loved it but she didn't ask to
sit in on a podcast but I like if my mom
has a superpower it's making everything
seem the best version of itself you know
like I could do anything here this could
be an awful podcast that we could do and
she would still walk out with glowing
reviews that I can guarantee you oh
you're gonna go back and brag to your
friends at your highschool reunion that
you're going to next she is absolutely
gonna do that
and if we can get a link and stuff you
know she will be sure yeah sharing that
around the that crowd will give you some
business cards you can't just push
Derek's channel anymore you got a you
got a push that's right some some good
mythical morning and some ear biscuits
amongst your friends you know put in a
good word for us I'll try really hard to
be entertaining right now more than
usual on this potty and we are trying to
break into that demo the demo that's
currently going to their 50 year high
school reunion that's weird they got a
lot of purchasing power oh yeah she's
been buying new stuff
no she's saving it up she's gonna she's
gonna buy some some of our merch okay
now I don't know if Linc Linc wants to
bring this up so I feel like I can be
the mediator here um but I think I know
what this is yeah actually
oh really okay oh really there's some
beef yeah there's a little bit of beef
but did I talk about this you know what
you didn't mention it cuz I I could tell
it was on your mind do you yeah cuz I
don't remember that I I know you know I
could see it in your eyes a little bit
the next time I saw you but also you
know I felt bad about it we gotta give
him the back when it happened yeah I
mean but this is good we haven't talked
about I think we I think I did mention
something because there's no way that
you know so I'm kind of follow up well
yeah you can you can tell it from your
perspective I I didn't even know what
happened when it happened you told me
about it later
this is how I remember it yep
it was VidCon and so vidcon's kind of
crazy like we were I think I'm pretty
sure we were introducing people on the
main stage and it was just like okay
here's some will introduce some people
they'll do it they'll do eight minutes
five minutes and then they'll come off
we're emceeing the thing and then we'll
come back out we'll crack a joke and
then introduce the next person so we
introduced you I guess or I got out on
so much you were out there somehow I
assume we introduced you but then when
you came back when you were when we were
coming when you were leaving and we were
coming out to stage to introduce the
next act yep yeah you punched me it's
that simple that makes it seem so
aggressive I mean as I remember it and
then you kept going kept going to do my
job but it happened in my periphery and
you didn't I didn't I knew nothing had
happened at the time but you told me
later that he came in kind of like a
punch like a hey do a good job kind of
punch but he really hurt yeah it was a
it wasn't in the face it wasn't in like
the chest like right in the center of
the sternum it was it was it was he
frogged you it was on the arm like we're
called it jerk all right
I've not called the back that's what I
think you were aiming for the deltoid
yeah with a little yeah a little fist
bump to the deltoid yeah fist bump it
was it was a fist bump motion that was
the attempt but it was a little low so
it was that spot where the deltoid ends
and then the next muscle starts to pick
up and it got right to the bone there's
a lot of bone there on me well you know
I'm just gonna say in my defense I I
think what happened was the adrenaline
huge act of being on stage exactly you
know how it can happen and it was an
attempt at a friendly gesture yeah yeah
yeah I mean two performers entering an
exiting stage yeah yeah but I remember
upon making the punch that it felt
harder than I intend I was leaving
leaving
and I was feeling like a jerk cuz I was
like now he's got to go out there he's
got a sore arm oh did you that you had
feelings
bye-bye I sensed immediately you know
it's like what probably saw my eyes
shudder
yeah it's one of those things where you
you really you don't intend it but you
know immediately that you've done it
wrong well and I I'm sure I didn't help
because I do remember having an
immediate emotional reaction like for
some reason I just the first like a
logical response was like you did it on
purpose
and I knew that that was not the kid
it's a I think it was a I'm not gonna
try to defend myself a science but let
me try to defend myself at sign okay
you hurt me unintentionally and it was
well intended it was a brotherly gesture
where I'm from they call it a love lick
yeah my granddad used to hurt me all the
time pinch me punch me and it was all a
little and it was a love look and say
I'm giving him a love lick yeah that was
how he showed affection mm-hm
and I I now believe that's what you were
doing yeah it were you just being
friendly let's just let's not make it
weird where's the science but you hurt
me you went in at granddad real quick
when it hurt me yeah this we're getting
into therapy not science I need some
help with that I had a physical pain
response that then was like fight or
flight and for some you know me
sometimes I'm like oh yeah even though I
have no business wanting to fight
anybody like my body said fight Wow my
body said that was that was a proper
Tori I did not know I did not know how
could you know we want to soon link one
of the fight somebody is a total jerk
and that would be me in that moment it
was like why it was a fight me I'd say
every 17 minutes it was not so
now take it person it was not it was not
personal it was biological right it was
somebody just hurt me I'm either gonna
run or I'm gonna try to hurt them back
mm-hmm there was your reptilian brain
there's my reptilian brain well I mean
can I say I'm sorry but I did I didn't
mean
and I'm sorry that you were hurt and I'm
also saying story of the Canadian yeah
I'm very which we probably appreciate
that at this moment the other thing that
I would offer to you is an opportunity
for a love like back oh if that is
something that you desire
I think it's warranted it's you know
it's something that I wouldn't permit
right here can we sell tickets to it or
do we need to do it right now well we're
gonna go Conor McGregor on this I mean
hey man they both made 200 million we do
like the youtube geek off version of
that like I have a glasses you know a
lot of stuff so that's really how I'm
I'm I'm lumping us together in that way
let's let that be a teaser let's say
we're not gonna get out of here we're
not gonna let Derek out of here until
you give him a love lick back oh I
thought you're gonna sing an answer yeah
an answer about whether well I'm the
fight promoter here I'm saying it's
happening
I'm not gonna set it off at a different
date I don't want to deal with all the
publicity and review stuff it's just
total headache so you want me to not you
want me to suspend forgiveness I mean
the dude said he was sorry this is
something that he didn't even have to
apologize this isn't about forgiveness
this is about revenge
I just love vengeance I think this is
about audience retention you're trying
to of course people can just get to the
end and see I can do them but I can't do
it I can't I can't let Derek sit over
there and say sorry and may not me not
say I forgive you I forgive you okay but
you know what I'm still gonna hit you up
ya know at the end of the show I feel
like I should apologize now come on
because that's ridiculous now I I don't
honestly I didn't hold a grudge I mean
once once my logic kicked in I was like
that made me mad right but it would be
stupid for me to think that he had Derek
had anything to do with it yeah but the
conversation we had logic doesn't always
kick in but we did have the conversation
you know it's actually Owen logic kicks
in for link it's like an audible noise
it's like a machine turns like oh that
that generator that hadn't started in a
couple of years it's dark now
oh so now that that's out of the way and
we're gonna do something to thin with it
so what we do often on this podcast is
just the two of us talk about things and
we don't really know anything about
anything but we like to talk like we do
know things about especially me I can
make you think I know about things I'm
glad you said that I could have a I
could have an incredible cult following
of stupid people you know there are
people that can do that good oh yeah
great cult starter that's just not
something you say out loud though no but
it is true it's a little bit like l ron
Hubbard or something yeah I would yeah
you could actually turn this into
something yeah right I mean I'm working
on my first novel right now okay and I'm
gonna come up with my version of
Dianetics but I am the only thing
standing in the way of him going over
some kind of edge I would not even give
it a label but the exciting thing about
having you here is that you actually do
know stuff I know some things yeah and
and so this is one of those those
situations where instead of just us
pontificating about things and then
checking ourselves later and we usually
just check ourselves on Wikipedia I mean
we don't even go to the source
sure so we're bringing the source to ear
biscuits now in the cool thing about
what you do is that you know you kind of
started this career on YouTube and now
it's gotten a lot bigger than that and
now you've got people like Bill Nye
sending you out places to be efficient
an official correspondent so this is
legitimate because some yeah because it
because here's the thing you know this
as well as we do that when you get
invited to these places and into these
environments but you're you're the
number one qualifier taps your name is
youtuber you kind of feel like you have
something to prove we feel like we got
something to prove as comedians when we
show up in a place but as a how do you
characterize yourself as a scientist
yeah you know I probably just say
youtuber these days right yeah it's like
man but with wit do you ever feel like
you have to like kind of explore I'm
doing on YouTube but it's like this kind
of legitimate at the same yeah I maybe
I've kind of given up on that you know
when I come through customs and stuff
and they'll ask me what I do and I make
videos on YouTube and you know they
actually look at my visa and you might
the technical term for my visa cuz I'm
not American the technical term
is alien of extraordinary ability oh
gosh credible right cuz we won't let you
in here unless you can do something that
no one here can exactly something
there's some sort of rationale and so
when I say to them at the border
you know I say I'm a youtuber and they
look at the visa and they're like what
extraordinary ability like what can you
do let's yeah and then then well then I
have to say like I'm on Netflix too and
as soon as I say that yeah that's
legitimate right like right I understand
my Netflix didn't depending on who I'm
talking to it doesn't say alien of
extraordinary ability but it says 11 now
when I just like category yeah
what now when I said let's see it I was
I was role playing as the guy at the go
but I am glad you're showing this too
because that's what I shot the guy at
the gate 11 yeah extraordinary
extraordinary ability that's probably
trademarked in some way somebody would
want to make a movie about that
good-looking photo it could be a lot
worse yeah it definitely could could be
a lot worse okay so so yeah I I
understand where you're coming from when
you mention Netflix they let you ride it
right that's right as soon as I say like
I'm on a show with Bill Nye on Netflix
oh yeah yeah I feel it man I know you
said you've given up but congrats on the
streaming win by the way thank you you
could also say that I want a straight I
don't know yeah if I said I want to
stream me they'd still be like man that
sounds made up
eeeh 11 extraordinary stream II winner
no no as long as I keep winning streamys
I'm not gonna dog it no yeah I'm not
gonna dog it I'm gonna let jon cozart do
that yeah okay so I we talk a lot about
self-driving cars yeah you know we're in
the middle of we're in the middle of the
transition yep
but I think the question what's at the
beginning of the transition really the
beginning of the transition okay see I'm
Mari have already been corrects all good
but when it like when can we just not
think anymore about getting from point A
to point B when is that gonna happen I
think it's gonna be a while but I'm
gonna say you know five years you could
probably make it happen you know that's
that's my horizon for that's yeah that's
quit it's it's soon
yeah but I don't think it's gonna be
widespread adoption at that time but
that'll be you know you your friend has
one or you know like it you know that's
when it's really coming in and then 10
years you know you see more widespread
adoption but I think it's gonna you know
five years is a good time horizon for
that and it will be a Tesla or by that
point do you guys drive Tesla's no I
wish
I do drive a Tesla I drove one here
today and it drove itself most of the
way here cuz I was just on the 101 so
right at what point I've actually never
let's see Joe Penna had a Tesla really
early on he had an early one and I wrote
it I got in it but then I didn't didn't
remove it I don't he had to be somewhere
like just let me get in it I've been
inside of Tesla so hang on you guys have
not ridden in a Tesla no I've not never
I have not been in a test but now John
who works here has won it has won so
we've got one in the parking lot that we
can probably take whenever we want it I
don't know why you guys haven't done
this yet you're sitting around talking
about self-driving car no I haven't even
sat in one well I care I got a car that
will park itself and I don't want to now
get in a Tesla and realize how stupid I
am forgetting excited about just being
able it'll parallel park itself yeah
well I mean that's a useful feature but
it's much more useful to just drive for
like half an hour on an open road so
let's take the trip here as an example
of how much of the time when could you
go into autopilot so to speak well you
can go in whenever you like but at the
moment the Tesla does not recognize stop
signs or traffic lights so you gotta
look out for those things if you're
gonna drive in that kind of situation so
the best place is a highway okay you
could just pop it in there and you can
go for you know an hour or more you do
have to keep sort of touching the
steering wheel to let it know that
you're still there I think that's some
lake legal requirement okay so it will
after a certain period of time it will
start trying to fly she said yeah and
that that time seems to depend on your
speed so if you're on a highway and
you're crawling through traffic you're
like 20 miles an hour you seem to be
able to go you know five ten minutes
without it alerting you but if you're
going super fast you know 65 70 it'll
it'll ask
probably every minute or so but it's
still ok so when you but when you get
off on the surface streets yep it knows
that it's on a surface Street and it
doesn't even let you engage no no you
can do it but you can totally engage on
a surface street and would it go through
a stop sign and you got it yeah oh yeah
if the I mean it'll just go up to the
car in front of you basically and so see
but that's it'll be it is informed by
all of the other cars so basically it's
just it's a follower a car more or less
so it's it by not but what if there's no
car in front of you then it's not gonna
stop for any stop sign it's not gonna
stop for any red light but as long as
there's a car in front of you that car
stops at the stop sign you'll kind of
stop behind it too and you'll do like a
kind of a rolling is there an
orientation to this oh it's totally just
like good luck man
here it is because I I don't I mean all
I knew is that everybody that I know who
has one just just does that on the
highway that I didn't know it was
because it didn't work on the surface
streets I just thought it wasn't capable
of doing it on the surface street I mean
it'll it'll do it it just you'll run
into more potential hazards for sure but
you but you can't program in a
destination and it make any turns for
you so the one that's commercially
available right now doesn't do that but
Tesla has released a video showing their
next generation model doing exactly that
you basically putting in your
destination and it just gets you there
yeah that's the time anyone that
includes stop signs that includes red
lights and they have the ability to do
it today but it's not been released yet
it's not been I think legally permitted
yet but I think you know the technology
is there today it's probably still a
little rough but it's there you know the
thing I don't understand is the you know
obviously there's the the resistance to
it and people who just don't trust it
which I just I cannot I appreciate it
but it for it really frustrates me when
people are like I don't trust it and
it's like look you trust humans you
trust people to drive cars million
people die every year and crashes I
think that our consciousness
I mean tricks
I mean I think a big thing about
consciousness is that it it tricks
yourself into trusting yourself like
even something like I know like this is
what I believe it's like okay I heard
you you heard that analogy to where it's
like okay what do you believe about
about like if something scares you and
then you like jump in
I'm blistering this analogy but like you
know not whither yeah jump in the bed
and you pull over the covers and you
would never say you believe that a
comforter is going to protect you from
danger yet it's revealed in that moment
what you actually believe I think that
applies to cars as well that we part of
consciousness is believing that the most
trustworthy person is yourself but
you're saying that's not true when it
comes to driving but I do want to have a
comforter in my car that's the whole
point I want to be able to take a
freaking nap I want to go to bed in my
car and let me so you don't trust
yourself to drive and you're making an
active decision to not trust yourself
trust the Machine oh I feel like you're
framing this in a way that I don't
necessarily frame it which is I find
driving just a less stressful experience
when I let the car drive and that's not
because I don't trust myself is because
like I can not really focus on driving
as much yeah well every time I mean just
you could just relax a bit you don't
have to push the pedal do anything you
know it's just like it's just going
especially if you're stuck in traffic I
mean it just was so so you're you're
it's a reminder for them for the
stressful yet kind of mind-numbing
experience of freeway driving
bumper-to-bumper stuff you're gonna
you're gonna let the Machine take over
exactly but when it gets complicated
you're gonna grab the wheel for now that
is absolutely true but at a certain
point there's gonna be a Thresh what's
the threshold look and feel like if
you're saying five years from now like I
think I dream now it's gonna be
happening because like I say they have
to get there they have they have the
cars built today the technology exists
it's just a matter of fine-tuning it and
the software and then getting the legal
approval for it I think the big blockage
is that we like a story where it's like
oh this guy was drunk and he hit someone
it's obviously his fault he caused these
deaths we can point to someone we can
say someone's wrong and evil but if
there's an autonomous car and this has
happened right the guy who got killed
driving a Tesla and you know who do you
blame in that in that situation and I
think we have a real problem with that
if self-driving cars start killing
people well who are you gonna be upset
with who's who's at fault there yeah
there's a quick you know whatever the
equation is just like how many you know
car calls deaths equal a human cause
death it's like there's we have some
weird scale yeah they were willing to
put up with all these people being
killed by you know themselves in cars
well the interesting thing about that
and and the guy who died was drew was
behind the wheel of the Tesla right yep
but and the thing I remember about that
is I don't remember the details of what
happened but I remember that Elon Musk
published the details in in a super
seemingly transparent way that was
mind-blowing to me in terms of hey this
is the actual data this is actually
what's what was happening and what the
car was saying and the level of
transparency there that he seemed to be
putting forward I think is what's gonna
get us over the threshold because it's
not it's not spin like there was nothing
about the statement that came out from
Tesla afterward that felt like the spin
zone or oh we got we got a we got to
protect we got to protect our money bagz
kind of a thing you remember do you mind
you I do I didn't dig too much into the
details but I I seem to recall a stat
like you know they can look at the miles
driven with the autonomous feature
engaged and compare that to the same
number of miles driven by people and
they find that you know it's 40 percent
safer 40 percent fewer accidents or
whatever per mile for for those driven
by the the machine so the machine is
better I mean it's it's more vigilant
with you know analyzing what's around it
and people are on their phones all the
time now I was driving but got behind it
guy today who was just like swerving all
over the place cuz he was on his phone
and probably shaving and reading - I
mean I've literally seen that in traffic
you know to me it's like whenever you
started using PayPal remember that first
feeling of like I'm a connect this bad
site to my physical bank account like I
can see like greenbacks just getting
disappearing through this thing called
PayPal it's it's even a stupid name why
would I trust this thing this guy's not
my pal I just bought some right but then
you you get over it and then you're like
when it I not have PayPal or venmo or
whatever it is these days to pay the
babysitter's you know you're saying
it'll be the same way and you say it'll
be five years five years at some point
before the five years you'll just you'll
fight you won't even realize that you
made a decision you'll just get in the
car and you'll be like oh I didn't I
didn't touch it
and then you'll think back and you'd be
like oh yeah there was a guy who worked
with me who had a cool car and I got it
and it was fun oh yeah we'll tell it fun
and our grandkids about the way we
thought about driving and it will blow
their minds they just won't have any
they just won't be able to comprehend
that it was ever a thing you know that
we did we approach things in this way
put those wing doors on it people want
about that's not gonna happen
okay so when you got the wing doors
that's a Fed there's a fat man oh that's
going away the wing doors are great you
think that's a staple I I don't think
it's a staple but I do love it hahaha
yours has that yeah we got wing doors
and it's really helpful for the baby for
the baby seat you know okay okay maybe
I'm wrong now okay so you're kind of
getting into something as well though
that as we transition you know when all
cars are autonomous with the exception
of like you know okay I've got this
really weird thing I have to net you
even beyond that when it's completely
autonomous
so you know they're all talking to each
other you know I can't wait for the day
when light turns green and the entire
mass moves together at the same time
because there's no reaction because
they're all talking together in the same
network mhm
like that's gonna be like second nature
right but
that kind of moves into this other
subject that we want to talk to you
about which is your perspective on AI
and you know it's all these things kind
of merging you you've got okay all the
cars are autonomous all the banking is I
mean even even banking and financial
management ultimately can be and should
be and is in a lot of ways you know
controlled by artificial intelligence so
what are we really up against like where
do you stand are you on the the Neil
deGrasse Tyson side which is like this
is no big deal we'll just unplug the
machine are you on the allama sam harris
side they're like so worried about it it
like this is the greatest problem along
with climate change that we face as a
species I feel like I'm more on the Neil
deGrasse Tyson side but that could just
be because you know both P and I are
scientists and maybe we're not fully
immersed in where AI is right now but I
find it hard to believe that I got a I
got a choose my words carefully
someone's gonna be playing this tape
back for me after the AI apocalypse at
like 2030 you assuming that you'll be
alive yeah long as you're there to hear
it when they play it'll be a robot
playing it back yeah here's what you
said and the voice was sound like that
you know there's there's a whole bunch
of things obviously not AI but that we
keep contained like you know very
dangerous diseases and things and we put
them in you know quarantined
environments because we don't want them
getting out and I feel like you should
be able to do the same thing with an AI
and didn't didn't Facebook have an AI
that came up with its own language and
they just they shut it down well well
they started I don't know if this is the
same thing but they the two there was
two machines that were communicating
with each other and they quickly
realized that English that language
human language was really inefficient
and they started communicating to each
other directly with bits you know just
straight digital communication that came
in at that point what are they saying
the the scientists could no longer
figure out what they were saying it that
is but but it all be is so crazy because
you know it's soon all the blog
this is why I but the reason i'm scared
cuz i I mean I don't are you more on the
Elon Musk's idea I am just because I
tended he's a hypochondria but I I mean
I'm super excited about the future like
I I embrace a lot of things probably
with less apprehension than I should
have but I yeah I think that because
they're gonna be that the moment that
they have true you know general
artificial intelligence and we can't
tell the difference between you know a
conversation with a human and a robot
they're already gonna be so much more
advanced than us just because of
processing and all that stuff that they
already have and at that point I just
feel like they could all the the
barriers that you're talking about like
keeping things contained it's like the
moment they just decide well we don't
want to be contained but they were one
of a quite are they connected to or do
they have arms and legs have we given
them that or well they're gonna be I
mean they're gonna have to be connected
to the inner Internet
see that's a terrible idea you know but
how are we not the same guy working in
his lab on a I you know I think that's
the rule it's like when you go to these
places that have have really harmful
diseases you have like three airlocks
and something you don't connect them to
the atmosphere because they could get
out they would and that would be awful
in the same way you you keep your AI
really locked up it's good I mean I
don't know how we're gonna do it though
because at the point that you've got
again I don't yeah
I don't think it's gonna be well
Westworld situation where you've got you
know robots walking around I mean what
we will have but that would be just for
us right it won't it'll be for our
entertainment or whatever but the most
powerful robots won't won't be contained
in the same way but they're gonna have
to have all eight in order to be useful
they're gonna have to be connected to a
network that we're using hmm yeah right
I feel like you want to be careful about
the ones you connect to your network
yeah this could be the like key plot
point of the movie of all goes wrong
we're so the one guy the mad scientist
yeah what's he mad about the one guy who
lets the virus out of the lab and this
isn't like a virus though you know it is
but it's way worse I still
wonder you know a server is not gonna
come after you you know what I mean you
know like a giant lumbering server is
that gonna be in here but I guess you
know to look at what could go wrong if
everything is connected to the Internet
and all your you know stuff in the
hospitals and all the the autonomous
cars and they get control of those yeah
it could be it could be pretty bad yeah
but who knows we don't I mean it's gonna
we're gonna be it's gonna happen we're
gonna be the midst of it and we're in
the thing is is that you know
politicians guys who are making the
decisions about this stuff just I don't
know anything about it like you've got a
few politicians who go like the extra
mile to kind of get briefed by some like
research assistant right but how many
people who like hold governmental office
actually know the potential threats
right it's like in its not many that's
for sure
do you guys ever think about the the
mass unemployment that may come with
yeah with the robots
well it I feel like that's clearly more
pressing right it's a more imminent it's
already happening yeah it's happening I
feel like that you're gonna deal with
first before you're gonna deal with
killer AI yeah so we got it we got a
serious we got a set of waves coming at
us let's talk about that I mean it's
interesting in buddy system season two
we kind of explore when I give I'm gonna
give too much away well it's the first
scene I mean the first scene of the
whole season is you losing your job to a
robot to a robot yeah no it is a
comically ridiculous robot whose no more
capable than a human but a joke but it's
all I mean we're not exploring what we
should talk about right now which is
what you're getting at but it is the
kind of job that we were replaced and I
mean number one most common job in the
u.s. is truck driver and Tesla is
building a truck that obviously is gonna
be autonomous it's some point so I
wonder it's gonna have and at first
there'll be somebody sitting there
just just in case yeah they'll work with
you know the laws were required yeah
right yep and he's just gonna like you
say he's gonna have to touch that big
steering wheel on the big rig ever so
often he's just a he's a wheel touch her
that's what he will be called on
monster.com waiting - we needed some
wheel touches they're not drivers their
truck wheel touches and then how long
how long is that gonna last after a
while year yeah they'll be gone yeah
yeah they'll be gone but before they're
gone I think that they'll be just seat
sitters and then they will replace the
seat sitters with basically like a CPR
dummy it someone who from the outside
that isn't it yes yes it is you got this
big rig barreling down the road you
don't you want to look and see nobody in
the cab you want to see what you think
they're gonna have a mannequin in there
you can they're gonna have a freaking
mannequin in there with a how about this
trucker hat how about just a sticker on
the outside of the window that just
shows the silhouette of a man of a
person well that's not an that's a lot
cheaper that'll be next yeah you're
skipping ahead can we just go I want to
go I'm straight to the decal kind of guy
let's do driver decal can I be the decal
oh I could be your profile sure I don't
care I'm not making the decisions I do
think that I mean really I mean so much
of this is public perception and comfort
level what are those guys get to make
things cool if you can make but what a
real question that is the bigger
question what are we gonna do as long as
we can agree that there will be dummies
in seats in order to make everybody else
fill out what is it when we can move I
feel like that's more frightening like
you're driving up next to a truck and
you look over and you're like wait hang
on that's not a real person that's a
dummy well it depends on your definition
of beauty is that what we're talking
about what makes a dummy beautiful no
we're not talking abut not talking about
so so do you think that because I know
some people think that you know they'll
just be the decal guy there'll be the
guy who places the mannequin in the
truck there's always something for
people to do but the new job you got to
run out of that eventually right yeah so
I mean it's something that I was really
interested to see looking back at his
three of work is that the number of
hours that we work has dropped a lot so
if you look in 1830 the average number
of hours that someone would work would
be 70 hours per week really yeah and you
look today and it's down to 40 and you
know in 20 years we may be down to 20
hours or something you know we may
continue to see that decline so maybe
even if the you know number of jobs
doesn't decrease that much the amount of
work per job may drop and we may just be
making more and/or spending less because
all the works being done by robots which
are much cheaper than humans mm-hmm so I
mean that's the hopeful utopian future
is that we could all decrease our work
hours down close to zero and yet still
survive and have you know wonderful
lives because all the things that we
want to buy are really cheap and so we
don't have to do that much work to get
the money to pay for those things but
what are we like so what I mean there's
what are the threats to that utopia
right you got the overpopulation problem
right yeah eventually you you you've got
if you got so many people like I feel
like the financial problem can be solved
like the people not producing it's like
what the robots are producing I but like
what about this being step that many
people a limited amount of resources and
all we do is just hang out and have a
good time yeah well to me one of the big
threats is that we sort of segment our
society further into people who have and
that the have-nots yeah there are gonna
be people who are making a killing off
this and there's gonna be people who
just are out of work and can't make any
money mm-hmm and so I think without like
a big rethink of how society functions
we may be in a really tricky situation
mm-hmm what do you think about universal
basic income I think it's interesting
and I think it's probably the way the
future how does that work well you just
give everyone some money yeah there's a
minimum amount that every single citizen
receives automatically from from what
organization the government from what
government the world government well
whatever government they're you're every
every nation we see foundation still
exist and they would have to buy into
this well I mean the nations would in
theory do it because it would be better
or easier than setting up a whole bunch
of other welfare
systems yeah and you know it's been and
it's being experimented with somewhere
Finland they've currently got a trial
with two thousand unemployed people
where they just pick two thousand
unemployed people at random and they
said we're gonna give you like 500 euros
a month yeah
but yet it seems absolutely inevitable
with all that with the trends that were
talking it's funny because you you say
it seems inevitable and I kind of think
it's a good idea but I was in
Switzerland last year and they actually
had a ballot about it so this is one of
those things where you know if you get
enough signatures they'll have a public
referendum about universal basic income
and they did this in Switzerland and
they voted it down I think 75 25 oh yeah
so it was pretty pretty harshly against
and I was talking to this guy at
university who's a smart guy you know
professor and he was like this is the
most idiotic thing ever and you know to
him it was obvious that this was never
gonna happen and of course the great
concern with universal basic income is
that nobody works anymore because they
can just get income and live off that
and so why would you ever yeah and so
the idea of disincentivizing any work
right and that's why I think it's cool
that's why I think it's inevitable
because I think it's just it's getting
it mixed up it's saying that well we
can't institute universal basic income
because then people will no longer work
well what I'm saying is that people are
gonna no longer work in the near future
because of the advance of you know
automation and so you gotta have an
answer to that and it can't just be like
whoa these people won't work it's I mean
I don't yeah I I was looking into this
actually I made a recent video about
robots taking our jobs and I was looking
at the percentage of males between the
ages of 25 and 54 who don't have a job
and if you look back in the 1960s it's
about five or six percent you know this
is prime working age males so like what
are they doing if they're not working
mm-hmm
but you look more recently and that's up
towards 18 and 20 percent so we're
looking at a tripling of males and their
prime working age you just don't have a
job and some of that may be due to
globalization outsourcing it but as
another part of that is automation and
and I can only see that going up so you
know you got to do something well
just let's say that utopia is gonna come
we're gonna we're gonna solve all our
problems with technology and we're gonna
find a way to quit exploiting all the
resources we're gonna solve climate
change let's just say all that happens
and our grandkids are sitting there
they've got some sort of stipend
everything all their needs are taken
care of at that point what is life like
right cuz don't I mean I think we can
definitely say that we find purpose in
our work right mm-hmm
you know that you do what you do because
you find purpose in it
I was substituting other things yeah I
mean I think everyone could they could
just have hobbies instead of work I'm
gonna do the little the little airplanes
like my little airplanes oh you're on
that side of town you you know the guys
over it
where are they at across in the Japanese
garden yeah over there in Balboa the
Balboa Lake area the guys with the
remote control control airplanes I have
not seen there's a whole Airport
dedicated to you know miniature planes
those guys are so serious
hang on hang on a whole Airport they can
have is it a miniature a minute yes okay
just a slab oh really
but they're so into it and they go out
there every weekend there's no terminals
you have it looks more like baseball
dugouts okay cuz they sometimes they
need to stand in the shade and order to
clear up but here's the weird it's the
Sun and like pilot their their planes
don't off if you lay down on your belly
and spread your arms out if you got
spread-eagle on the floor mm-hmm they
have planes of that base planes that big
oh yeah it's pretty big plane and I run
our thing these are like gas-powered
some of them are yeah some of them are
electric and but here's the thing I
think they're all powered by passion for
the Hobby we can't just go out and do
that because then all of a sudden guys
gonna show up and he's like I've got an
automatic plane I've got an autonomous
plane now it's just booze watching
outside his planes have a hobby we're
gonna watch planes make their own
decisions and that's our hobby all we
can do is put decals on them see it just
it just comes back to decals why is that
plane shooting down all the other
planets
I'm the owner I have no some robot in
the corner so this is your your idea of
utopia well we're exploring it you know
if you're saying everyone does hobbies I
wonder if people get caught up in gossip
if that just explodes yeah and then a
number of gossip mags out on the market
it's just you know it's everywhere whole
store is dedicated to it
I guess not stores yeah no you're right
these stores I think though I think
it'll be a retro thing where it's like
it you know it's a whole store that
replicates the experience of exiting a
grocery store you know that all of that
impulse buy crap it's this is a good
idea this is my business no robots gonna
come up with this in the future a store
that's nothing but the last little bit
of grocery aisle before you check out
the check out check out ragout area yeah
check out area everywhere yeah is what
I'm gonna call her that's catchy
and then you when you come in you check
out when you get in you check out again
you just keep checking out because like
oh man I gotta make a decision
I can grab one more thing and then it
starts over yeah and then you just got
all those little dividers and you could
be yeah I love it yeah you're not
because you're right yeah it all be
digital it all be in your brain but
there's no aisles there's no area to
actually buy right the useful staples of
life right there's only the checkout
area it's amazingly described in a
dollar store I think let's just not use
claw so you recreated a dollar store a
lot more conveyor belts um it's what
we're saying now I think one of the
interesting things that is is probably
also gonna happen with this is and this
is what I cut I kind of foreshadowed
this in the past I was gonna and how I
thought about AI and how it you know I
don't know how I set it up but basically
I think that you know we've got all
these issues that are controversial
people can't agree on things and then
we've got this faulty government model
that we rely on with
a questionable dude in charge of the
whole thing and wouldn't you just like
to say okay I want to ask this robot
that is completely familiar with all the
data like what do you think about this
issue and then they would just spit it
out and it would be like we can't argue
with that robot because that robot has
access to all the information at once
and it's perfectly rational and has no
bias at all except the bias that makes
its way in from the programmers which
okay but well I think that's I think
you're describing a scientist in its
purest form but you know but scientists
are people and so you're right that
inherent distrust of people but I think
you know since scientists make the
machine I don't know if there's any way
to keep their biases out of the machine
and they're right therein lies your
problem it is like it is a problem but
can't we had can it be a more perfect
rationality than we can ever achieve
right what I'm getting at is aren't we
gonna have an AI government at some
point I mean is it or at least a
government that is assisted by AI so in
other words it would probably be you
know how quick governments are to adopt
technology future so you've got like you
know it's gotten uh I think your point
is to move it's like for the financial
system thing well if that if things have
to get really bad for entire governments
to agree to do something we're talking
about the switzer just think about the
way that the government works right now
think about the way that people get
elected and like campaigning and like
influencing people's thoughts people who
the vast majority don't ever think about
things on a on a deep level they just go
out and vote for somebody who has an ad
that though that appeals to them in some
way or some ideology that they identify
with and that person gets put in this
position they don't know about this
issue in that issue and then they just
start listening to people who don't know
about that issue tell them what they're
supposed to think about that issue and
that's all these very very flawed humans
making all these decisions like that
system in in when you've got an
intelligence that is ultimately a more
capable intelligence that is grown
at some point you're gonna have to tap
into that for the sake of humanity all
right I mean I I'm not in the Star Trek
enough to know more than saying you're
talking about Spock I mean let's figure
out Spock was like utterly logical spot
for president so what did we learn
yeah what do we learn from Spock
sometimes sometimes his logic wasn't
enough that's what we learned
you got it right that's why you have the
parental of people who are keeping the
AI government in check
it's not I'm not saying this community
are miles but then they're like hold on
okay we need to know what to think about
this let's throw it let's throw the
problem into the Machine see what the
machine says and then this panel of wise
people decides what to do so it's not
completely led by the AI but you gotta
be consulting so you're saying it's not
the president is like the cabinet and I
mean literally a cabinet like the
president's the president's chief
adviser is AI is a cabinet a literal
cabinet yeah with a server in it yeah
it's like throw it in the top of the
cabinet and then it'll spit something
out of the bottom answer out of the
bottom of the cabinet yeah it's it
sounds like a cool idea
I always just fear about that whole you
know garbage in garbage out kind of
problem of Technology where if you don't
phrase the question right or you don't
give it the right data you're not gonna
get the right thing out at the end right
so kind of troubling and I'm this
morning my my son Lando who's seven was
like okay google play the slinky song
because he was playing with a really big
slinky and it started playing a really
inappropriate R&B track by some guy
named Don by slinky or something I was
like whoa Google whoa Google yeah it's
hard it's hard to rein her in I also
winner you know went home when do we get
an artificial intelligence that is you
know truly deserving of that name like
to me artificial intelligence always
meant something that was a computer that
that had its own consciousness yeah but
I don't know that we're close to that
and I also don't know that anyone can
can time that out for you like oh we're
not there yet but give us
five years will be there or 10 years it
could be a hundred years could be a
thousand years because we don't know how
the human brain works yet I think it's
really tough to make something that
replicates those capability right we
actually don't know how we're gonna
cross that threshold and we've but we've
always been obsessed with it I mean
Frankenstein wasn't wasn't written a few
years ago no I don't know when it was
written don't ask me but I know it's old
you know it's as as long as we've been
conscious we've been obsessed with
creating consciousness so I think if
we're just driven do you think bound to
figure it out we're gonna get there just
based on that principle alone like just
drive what if it's impossible what if
what if it's impossible to replicate in
a machine you know that is a question
illogically that is a spiritual question
so I have no clue my and the fair is a
very fair my feeling on this and this is
just going with my gut which could be
totally wrong right because it's yeah
not not a thinking organ but but really
yeah I just don't feel like we're gonna
get there and certainly not soon but I
definitely don't think it's gonna be
soon so I don't think it's gonna be like
2045 or something you know the
singularity right but I don't know I
just feel like it's I think that I don't
think it's gonna be like somebody's
gonna walk out one day Mila I got it I
got this this is here it is talk to it
here is Frankie I think we're gonna it's
gonna get so close and we're gonna we're
gonna have conference intelligent
conversations with machines and then
after we're all gonna be like well we've
kind of given this machine all we can
give it and I kind of think that it's
conscious now but well it's it's at the
same time we're gonna be I mean we keep
trying to find where consciousness
exists right in us like where's the self
inside a brain and we have no idea we
have no idea so I don't know I I agree
with you that I don't think that it's I
don't think it's gonna happen
lifetime I really don't I think I think
things will get unrecognizable in our
lifetime technology wise but I don't
think it's gonna we're not gonna have
you know AI president well let me ask
you what are you most excited about the
future and it can be the distant future
and what are you most concerned about
maybe that's climate change maybe that's
something else Wow
tough questions cuz I mean I don't often
think about the distant future but I do
like the idea of of humans becoming a
multi planetary species oh let's save
the good start with the bad because I'm
okay great so we'll come back to that
word yeah it's tough to pick what's your
biggest concern I'm not a big warrior so
I don't have a lot of concerns but what
about you guys pack quite a punch though
well see it doesn't come from a place I
hate you tend to be violent it
undersurface right it only comes from a
place of love maybe I haven't fully
forgiven you I don't know why that came
it did it does seem like it right now
yeah I can feel the tension across this
table ah yeah what are the what are the
bigger biggest problems being a guy like
you are and being an expert in the
things that you are in this particular
like in America right like we have this
really weird sort of dichotomy of like
being super advanced and like world
leader but then we also have like
there's so much resistance to scientific
thinking and also a lot of resistance to
just scientists in general and a lot of
distrust you know where we come from
North Carolina it's just like scientists
are suspects scientists have agendas and
scientists are trying to get grants and
so that's the only reason they're
talking about climate change or this
yeah right yeah yeah it's a diverse
country you can you can say that I also
saw this study which looked at opinions
of scientists in countries around the
world and there was a clear negative
correlation between GDP
you know how developed a country was and
its perception of scientists so
countries that are still developing
they love scientist and have this
this idea that they are solving problems
and really helping everyone live better
lives and in countries where you know
they're already very developed
everyone's quite skeptical of scientists
I think it's interesting that sort of
the more benefit science gives you the
more you don't like it or trust it or
you know I think it's a great thing it's
kind of unfortunate I consider this
sometimes like the curse of prevention
mmm this applies to things like vaccines
where people don't know what the disease
is like and so they freak out about you
know a shot because I can't even see
like what am i preventing right so yeah
that is the curse of prevention doing
all this good stuff I think you know
everyone has biases and they really
cloud your judgment and so when you talk
about you know people distrusting
scientists it comes from a place I think
of you know not being wanting you know
not wanting to be told what to do and
being told that what you do is wrong and
hurting the planet and that you have to
change and it's going to be painful and
expensive and hard and you know for
something that seems very intangible and
deep in the future and invisible so I
can really understand where this is like
a Rorschach test where you know even the
people on the Pro you know we need to do
something about climate change side can
maybe be somewhat detached from the
evidence and people on the anti cider
also detached from the evidence and they
just battle in the middle over you know
some sort of ideological or you know
virtue sync signaling ground or identity
politics all that sort of stuff so
everything gets really really awful I
think well and and we and it seems like
and it's interesting because you know
Bill Nye is really he tends to insert
themselves into these into these things
for sure and it doesn't really matter
what issue it is he is doing a lot of
great things but at the same time
there's this when he says okay I'll go
and I'll debate this guy or I'll go on
this this network and it'll be me and
then this other guy
and it creates this false perception
that this is a real there's a real
debate to be had here and I'm not saying
there's not a debate to be had about
issues but sometimes when you just
reduce it down to two pundits you know
and these in these you know what do you
call it the news bit what do you call
the thing Talking Heads
Talking Heads but like you got a news
bite or whatever like a sound bite sound
bite yeah it reduced things down to
sound bites a paints the issue wrong for
a lot of people and gives you this idea
that you know I don't know I mean I
agree with you I just don't know who's
you know what other alternative you what
do you do it's it's like you have no
option because either bill goes on that
show and actually debates some guy or
that guy just pontificates by himself
it's true and and gives the same sort of
bad talking points yeah it's a really
tough one because the network's are
gonna still do I mean they're gonna do
that that's how they're going to
dispense the information yeah this kind
of makes me think of something a little
bit of a tangent but the people on the
you know Pro climate change side Pro
climate changing the you know the people
who who think this is an issue and they
want to do something about it sometimes
they don't change acknowledge or yeah
acknowledge errs there will sometimes
write inflammatory rhetoric there are
some people like Naomi Klein and I
haven't read her book about climate
change but I have read the back cover of
it and it basically says that you know
climate change is an indication that our
our system is not working that
capitalism has failed and that you know
we need massive revolution to you know
change everything and you know let's
let's harness this issue as an
opportunity to change everything the way
we want it to be and I can understand
that freaking out people you know who
don't have that sort of ideology and
really getting their backs up and making
them more suspicious of you know what
scientists are talking about so in a way
I feel like stuff like that there's a
real disservice when you're trying like
I would love for us all just to come
down to the fundamental issue of raising
the temperature of the planet by a
couple degrees which I don't think is a
contentious issue scientifically and
then thinking about that as kind of a
risk factor there's a guy who's a
kind of lobbyists for Republicans and I
love the way he sort of talks about it
which is we acknowledge us as a
potential risk for the future and you
don't know how bad it's gonna be might
be really really bad or it might just be
like kind of bad but banks for one have
a lot of experience with dealing with
potential risks in the future and what
do you do when you have a risk which you
know has a small probability of being
terrible you hedge against it and you
you you sort of pay in a certain amount
up front to make sure that never happens
because if it did happen you know
there's nothing you could do that would
make you whole so it's just it's
fundamentally this sort of it's a risk
management game and he's trying to talk
to people and say like who cares how bad
you think this is gonna be and who cares
you know how much you really acknowledge
this you can consider that it is a risk
that it is something with uncertainty
which everyone acknowledges and what do
you do in the face of an uncertain risk
take steps to mitigate it and that's
where I'd love to see us go is this
place where we acknowledge it as a risk
some uncertainty in the future and
something that we should probably take
some measures to prevent right and
you're saying that right now the two
sides of the debate are alarmism yeah
and and kind of demonizing anybody who
questions it and then people who just
deny it yep and those are the two camps
and so where's the action gonna take
place if we just be like well guys
something could be happening and that's
something that's happening could be
really bad and what can what can we do
what are the practical steps that we can
agree on mm-hmm you know I think that's
a pretty reasonable perspective I'd love
for us to get there I you know I feel
like media has made things and and I
kind of refer to the like the Internet
and social media has Amol made this much
worse hmm it's funny to think like where
would we be policy wise if it's it was
1999 now you know what I mean in terms
of technology and everything we didn't
have Twitter or Facebook or YouTube
obviously we wouldn't be here but but if
you know what I mean like the Internet's
allowed people to find their voice well
and also the people like them oh yeah
and really get into these camps oh yeah
would we
be more integrated if we had fewer
communications technologies yeah that is
the really ironic thing that's happened
we're more connected and more divided
than ever we were talking I was talking
with somebody about this other the other
day and we were talking about what we
thought about issues you know in the 80s
or how we learned about things and it
was just like there's a couple of people
that knew stuff there was a couple of
outlets and of course in one sense that
information was controlled by people who
may have been deceiving the public but
in another sense it's like you didn't
have this like this is my guy this is my
internet guy this is the website I go to
and this this is this these are the
people who have it right right and I
also feel like people had a greater
sense of integrity for some reason maybe
it was out of this false notion that
they couldn't push the envelope too far
you know like even if someone was
controlling the news you know back in
the 80s they would never dream of like
putting on false stories or anything
because it you know that's ridiculous
who would ever do know we have some
integrity and then these days you know
it's like anyone could put anything out
there and then you can blow up without
anyone's oversight so that's a really
scary position to be in
I also think you know media has made it
so there's a big market if you want to
be extreme on this side or extreme on
this yeah there's not a lot of a market
for the middle right and that's really
kind of unfortunate and I think does
that this you know a massive disservice
to the entire discourse well it's
interesting because podcasts have kind
of changed this in one sense it's like I
think about that all the time when I'm
listening to people talk about complex
issues on podcast I'm like this never
happened on the news oh yeah like you'd
never get into something like that and
actually hear somebody break something
down yeah not a sound bite a sound meal
sound meal
now that's what your biscuit actually
means link sound meal but let me see let
me shift gears to the the the
speculative distant future that you are
most excited about like it could be
I don't know it could be a autonomous
beard trimmer well he said multi
interplanetary travel that's weird yeah
is that what it is yeah
you know multiplanetary species that's
my vision for the future and and it's
also really that thing of liberation
from work which is something we kind of
talked on earlier yeah in the podcast
but you think about the history of
humans as a species and from the very
earliest times you know we've been about
doing the fundamental work needed to
survive you know getting food and taken
care of you know family and stuff and
that's about all we had time for yeah
and then you move through the
agricultural revolution and you start to
get you know artists and writing and
poetry you know things start to enrich
our lives and move through the
Industrial Revolution and the number of
people who can do those sorts of things
really increases and now we're going
through you know further revolutions
with this technology and so I'm
imagining a future where people don't
think about you know what is my job so
that I can pay for a living and I can
support a family I can you know find
food you're thinking about people who
really pursue their interests and their
passions and they have the freedom to to
do that and also do it in space
yeah replacing desperation with hobbies
is that how we're gonna overcome you
know the population problem is going to
other planets oh I I somewhat I'm
optimistic that we can support everyone
on earth right uh you know there there
may be a few more billion but the again
you look at the massive trends of the
last you know a few thousand years and
it is reducing the amount of work and
it's also having fewer babies in
developed right yeah I'm hoping that we
see that you know I think we're already
seeing it the the birth rates starting
to level off in a lot of places and so
hopefully we reach a point and you know
we have the capability and the
technology to produce enough food and
you know I think it is possible but I
think you know for the long-term
survival of the human species it's a
good idea to be on multiple planets and
I also think you know space exploration
would be one of my top goals
if I was in government it wouldn't be
growing the military it would be growing
the NASA budget so what about getting to
these I mean Mars is one thing right but
are you not not excited about Mars no I
like I'm waiting for Pluto well you know
we we went to JPL and they let us walk
around the Mars yard and it was I mean I
gotta say it was pretty underwhelming
him it was just it was just that to just
kind of a dirt I mean it is NASA Deena
it's you know it's not Mars right to be
fair so well it's a dirty back line but
if that's what Mars is like I'm like
well what about the earth-like planets
that we can actually get to Wow yeah cuz
we can't get to any right now right so
we're gonna have to figure out some tech
if we're gonna get to so yeah we're
gonna do that like what's the what's the
closest one that they discovered like
how many like I mean 20 light-years is
probably your best bet in terms of
earth-like planets and so you know is
this gonna be are we in a what is it
what's the movie where Chris Pratt some
passengers yeah passenger so is it that
kind of situation where we got people in
some sort of you know cryogenic freeze
some state and we just it's just you
were propelling them across the universe
I feel like the first thing we'd send is
robots do they send robots first in that
movie I haven't seen I heard it was bad
I didn't watch it yeah I heard it just
started in the middle of the journey so
there was no robot around uh I wonder if
you just send a colony you know a group
of people who could live and like have
kids and they could have kids and by the
time you get there you know it's your
fifth grand chills in the place but your
other option you know the crazy thing
about relativity is that if you go fast
enough the distance gets shorter this is
the crazy thing about special relativity
so for example if you could go nearly
the speed of light Oh point nine nine
nine the speed of light mm-hmm then to
someone on earth it would seem to take
about 20 years to get that distance you
know for that for that person to arrive
there but for the people inside the
spacecraft it would actually take much
less time right this is the crazy factor
but how are we gonna get that fast well
that's the key we got to find a good
energy source and that's
probably going to be something like
fusion could be fission it's probably
gonna be fusion nuclear fusion so the
same thing that powers the Sun doesn't
sound dangerous at all right but I mean
people are working on it right now yeah
they're trying to get a reactor up in
Europe right now to actually make power
out of fusion so the same thing this
happens in the Sun just combining
hydrogen atoms together squeezing them
together making helium and other sorting
that's happening yeah people are working
on it in fact they've been working on it
for decades
the problem that they've been having is
they put so much energy into heat the
particles up and get them you know ready
to do their fusion thing that they
actually get less energy out of the
fusion process okay should put output
issue right but I think we're very close
to that sort of tipping point inflection
point where we're actually going to
start getting more out than we put in
well and at the moment that you reach
that point doesn't that basically just
that becomes our energy I mean you don't
have you don't even need solar at that
point right yeah I mean that's like
solar on Earth you're making your own
star kind of thing but but actually
getting the technology to be affordable
and you know stable easy to use that you
know it'll take time so it's kind of
like showering so hard that you make
yourself stink
I don't know that yeah you expend so
much energy oh yeah yeah you go hard in
the shower you gotta be careful right
I've never ever right take a tub bath
oh man I gotta get you got to get out
more than you put in
that's if I want to stink coming out of
the shower definitely not this is a
question I've often had with my friends
like swimmers when they go in the pool
mmm do they sweat oh gosh
see and can they answer the question I
don't know I'm no summer I'm not friends
with swim you got all you got to do is
take a sample man but how do you do it I
mean they're wet anyway that's a good we
got a video for your channel is it do
swimmers sweat nay title thumbnail
everything can we can we collab go hard
and shower yeah will do go hard on the
ship a good title on our chin and it's
just it's just total clean science it's
not what you think it is yeah
I don't that's a good one okay well
there this has been a great conversation
of course we can't just end it here
because we promised that you and you
guys would settle your score yeah you
guys so why don't before you settle your
score remind everybody where they can
find you on the internet you can find me
with the word veritasium it's everywhere
yeah very we're very taking Varitek I
can't even say it now veritas you can't
even say my anger it's because of the
anger that is deep inside veritasium is
found wherever it's found its you yeah
hopefully no one's impersonating no
one's true I got that trademark so what
you want me to punch him yeah to end the
pike I want you to give him a love lik
when you give him a love lick I just I
think listen it would make you feel
better I think just getting that in you
think that I I got so much pleasure out
of turning this into entertainment for
everybody that I feel like I can't punch
well you could hug him real hard hug it
out
listen I'm gonna put it this way I'm not
gonna I have no revenge in my heart I
have only love and forgiveness and
respect and I just consider it an honor
to have been punched by the hand that
held the world's smoothest object around
us around us object roundest yes okay
well you know what I mean it was it was
the most perfect sphere it's the most
beautiful it wasn't smooth well of
course it has to be smooth in order to
be there rounded but it's not the
smoothest no that that is a question
that's a baby's bottom we'll call a pond
that too so you're not gonna hit him no
I'm not gonna hit him that's stupid I
mean they're still listening mission
accomplished
okay now we let him tell because see
this is him man this is him playing a
producer and it's not Don King man look
at that we're shaking it a white audio
listeners we're giving it a nice semi
firm handshake I squeeze it like there's
some vibrational energy happening there
and Wow yeah I love the hell of the
science on this podcast lean out to the
forgiveness forgiveness gives a good
fizzle it does
[Music]